what's the craziest thing is it really
it's a bad idea no it's not a bad idea
what's the craziest thing with your own
eyes you've seen at the uh at at the
Gathering that you can talk about
allegedly that you allegedly saw with
your own eyes no man I I allegedly
nothing to Gathering is off the [__]
chain I dude I want to I want to [__]
go in the middle of Ohio right bro
listen I I I I really advise you to go
account of this I know you're a wise man
MH and there's nothing worth more than
experiences memories for sure you know
what I'm saying and you will absolutely
never forget not if you live to be a
thousand right going to the Gathering
bro and and there is
absolutely no [__] danger right
that's the biggest misconception wait
didn't didn't somebody get booted off
stage it was was it Tila Tequila yeah
that I saw and then didn't who is unless
you're an artist unless you're an artist
and they don't like you cuz wow what a
weird thing I just said there's no
danger and then you're like what about t
unless you're an artist absolutely
you're right there has been rappers that
they've thrown [__] at [__] yeah my
heroes bro i' I've seen man I've seen
some of my heroes go down and leave the
stage you know what I mean wow like who
Too Short oh they almost got Old Dirty
Bastard off oh and it was I believe the
last concert of his life wow oh you had
ODB at the Gathering right before he
passed away yeah that's crazy were you
able to talk with him when he got there
who was up there somebody ran up there
with
ODB and was like cuz they were throwing
[__] and obb was starting to get mad you
know I I mean they throw [__] that's
what they do they're not always trying
to hit you right they're just throwing
[__] look at in the air they throw [__]
there's just [__] flying everywhere
including at the stage you know and some
people don't know how to do it other
people like yellow wolf that
[__] caught you know and drank
it and the place popped you [__]
Stone Cold catching a beer on the
[__] exactly the crowd loved it like
he's he's saying I got no problem with
this yeah I'm rocking this you know what
I mean and and um that's what you the
kind of energy you have to have cuz
sometimes guys get up there and they get
they want a thug you know and that is of
course the worst thing cuz if we th on
one
Jugo Gathering of the good jug
everyone's turning against you're in the
wrong place you know what I'm saying
yeah no as as that's crazy I didn't know
you guys had o or even if you're up
there trying to act like you're too
harder than them right right right right
right and you know what I'm saying the
only ones that ever got away with
clearly looking harder than them was
[__] um last
year who played last year the the main
group
I can't remember I'm getting so dumb um
not suicide boys the other um um those
dudes I know you talking about um city
morg city morg yeah city morg city morg
go up there bro they killed it they
killed it [__] slat them wow like I
that's they love that Wicked [__] city
morg is is a a version of a wicked [__]
and suicide Bo listen to they do that 36
mafia [__] yeah it's like very [__]
36 suicide was a very very 36 mafia
style I feel like DJ Paul's kind of
adopted the Jugo SL
American pretty heavily me and DJ Paul
are are actually [__] very close no
he's a great guy he's so [__] great
man you know what I'm saying we did an
album together he wouldn't stay at my
house I have my studios in in my front
yard right
he wouldn't stay at my house because he
didn't like the woods I live and he's
like [__]
that I'm like what what do you think a
bear is going to jump through the window
or something that's crazy but he's the
[__] man he's so dope I love him man